all right in honor of the olympics and
in order to best hype the coming
olympics we're going to give out
bronze silver and gold medals based upon
work done by teams in the off season so
the bronze medal
awarded by shereen williams goes to
which team
i'm giving it to the cardinals mike i
just think that some of these veterans
they sign were key additions that you
know
some of them are going to be starters
some of them are going to be reserves
who are going to contribute a lot of
playing time and some stats and
everything else but you look at this
list of guys who are 30 and over jj watt
a.j green matt prather malcolm butler
james connor colt mccoy brian winters a
lot of those have pro bowls uh on their
dot on their uh resume so these are
going to be good additions to the
cardinals but i tell you what it does
mike
it puts in my mind a ton of pressure on
cliff kingsbury to get this team to the
postseason and look at the division they
play in it is an extremely tough
division perhaps the hardest division in
the nfl but to me he's going to have to
get this team to the playoffs or he may
be looking uh at a pink slip after the
season's over
i'm going with the browns uh for the
bronze just because it sounds like
bronze and because they have done some
good things they've maintained their
nucleus and they've they've added john
johnson the safety from the ram so the
rams would have very much liked to have
kept and troy hill from the rams as well
jumps over to cleveland and on top of
all that today the addition of jadavian
clown who if healthy can help that
defense reach a new level so browns have
done some great work and the browns it's
just weird to get used to this idea that
the browns are
one of the better teams in the nfl we
had 20 years of them just being one of
the teams that's hanging around
not this year browns are looking pretty
good
the browns are looking pretty good it
still all goes back to baker mayfield
mike a key year for him to get it done
uh for the browns but i like what
they've done this off season
all right silver medal shereen who you
have
i'm gonna go with the jaguars you know
this is a team that really needed a shot
of excitement for the city and i think
they started that by the coach they
hired going out and getting urban meyer
it may or may not work it's an
experiment but if it does it's gonna
work brilliantly it's going to be a huge
addition to them if it doesn't work hey
they're the jaguars they start over
again they've done that many times in
the history of this team and then i
think the draft they're going to drive
trevor lawrence we all believe that it's
going to be another shot in the arm i
just think there's going to be a ton of
excitement in jacksonville but then you
look at what they're get what they've
done in free agency i just think they've
improved themselves with shaquille
griffin and marvin jones and jamal agnew
and carlos hyde now woods and philip
dorsett and damian wilson and all the
guys they've signed they signed a ton of
guys i don't think this is going to be
the worst team in the nfl next year
they're going to win more than one game
mike they're going to end that 15 a game
losing streak pretty quickly
yeah i agree with you i don't know how
good they're going to be and i don't
know what i would peg their their real
over under at i think the folks at
points bed had them at six and a half
which is a dramatic jump from one last
year but uh they're on the right track
we'll see urban meyer making the
adjustment to the nfl i think is the
biggest challenge that that team has for
me the silver washington football team
when you consider that they brought in
curtis samuel a very underrated receiver
william jackson iii at corner they've
also added adam humphreys slot receiver
and there he is on the left brian
fitzpatrick hoping for fits magic i like
what the best team in the nfc east has
done to try to get a little bit better
and we were talking about this earlier
today cowboy's still the betting
favorites to win that division they do
such a great job of hyping that team and
setting the bar unrealistically high
every year and then most of the time
they fail to achieve those expectations
and if i'm washington i love the fact
that i'm not regarded as the favorite in
the division i think that helps set it
up for them to win the division again
yeah 25 consecutive years the cowboys
have failed to live up to those
expectations mike can they do it this
year we'll see they have the best
quarterback in the division but i too
like what washington has done
all right who's at the top of the podium
for shireen williams for the offseason
so far
i'm going with the defending super bowl
champions because i think they've set
themselves up to have a repeat mike all
22 starters are back i never thought
they would be able to resign all the
guys they resigned they got everybody
back abs the only guy out there and i
don't think they really care whether
they get him back or not but just
getting chris godwin and sue and shaq
barrett and levante david and then they
add
geo bernard and scott mclendon
rejoined them again this week so i mean
they've just done all the right things
to me and free agency getting this team
back together they've got a great chance
to repeat they're deep they're as deep
as any team in the nfl if you start to
bet on teams i'm definitely betting on
the tampa buccaneers to go out and
repeat and i realize it's harder to
repeat than it is to win the first one
but oh my gosh this is a loaded team
to bring all those guys back
to still have
that tom brady mentality
and to address your weaknesses after
you've signed all your guys you know the
fact that they signed giovanni bernard
as an outsider that that tells me that
maybe they've closed the door on antonio
brown i i i don't i
i i'd i'd be concerned and i've said
this a few times about bringing antonio
brown back because of that looming civil
lawsuit and the reality that he's going
to be questioned under oath at some
point probably sooner rather than later
and i i have a feeling that he's not
going to perform very well and it's
going to potentially jeopardize his
ability to play in 2021 and they may
just be better off looking elsewhere to
round out the depth chart at receiver
the draft is still coming up maybe they
could get a young guy there i still hold
out hope that larry fitzgerald who has
yet to announce his plans for 2021 will
join the buccaneers we're having fun
with the idea that julian edelman can
end up there although i really don't
think it's going to happen it's fun to
talk about it happening the connection
with brady and gronkowski but it is
amazing what they've done to hold
together
all the starters both sides of the ball
and they're going forward again and they
were seven and five it's amazing a team
that was seven and five
at their bye week has managed to win
eight in a row and win every battle that
they've faced in the offseason by way of
keeping guys around for me it's the team
that tom brady came from the new england
patriots even though they were seven and
nine there's this sense they were
horrible four and twelve three and
thirteen no they were seven and nine
there were games they could have won
that they lost like the game against the
kansas city chiefs the monday night or
when all of a sudden they didn't have
cam newton and the game got delayed
today they gave the chiefs everything
they could handle but for some
boneheaded decisions at the quarterback
position specifically one from brian
hoyer maybe they could have stolen that
game now cam newton's back they went out
and they spent all that money on
upgrading the tight end position with
johnny smith and hunter henry and the
receivers added nelson aguilar and
kendrick bourne and all the things
they've done defensively with matthew
jude on amazing array of talent to make
a bad team better and when you have bill
belichick you don't have to be
a super bowl caliber talent team you
just have to be close and bill belichick
and company are going to do the rest and
put guys in the right position to win
those games that a lesser team or a team
with a lesser coaching staff would lose
shireen
and i would love to see them get one of
these quarterbacks that we keep talking
about mike in the first round i think
that would round off uh what they've
done in this off-season that's been a
really productive one for the patriots
so say justin fields who they went and
watched today if they could end up with
him somehow some way i think would be an
outstanding off season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports